non mais t'es plus moche que nous lui
non mais tu dis qu'à sa tête de cul de
l'univers se veut être un cadre des
normes assad à tout ça je ne prends pas
du tout quoi suis-je j'imagine que tu
voudrais pas trop sortir avec moi non
mais t'as vu ta gueule
toi ton argent tu vois des capotes
j'espère encore est inquiète
il
alors s'instaurer
la mère du musée quoi je me souviens tu
as fait ton corps bien fait ton corps
elle fait encore n'importe quoi
aujourd'hui la cerec comme un homme
comme un homme tant pis à part ça je
peux pas éviter de raconter mon histoire
personnelle tant chéri autorails
oula entre nous c'est super sérieux on a
parlé de faire des enfants et tout
ouais mais ça c'est pas qu'en roulant
des pelles qui arrivent il faut mettre
les faisait se lever
je crois que je traumatisé je trouve a
fait quoi qu'est ce qui prouve que tu me
saute dessus comme ça qu'est ce que tu
as avec ton clip est un problème non
seulement j'ai compris je suis moche
j'ai un gros pif
j'ai des boutons des peines qui soulève
donc quoi c'est juste qu'on trouve pas
sur les filles comme ça il est trop beau
et trop moche c'est bien terminé
c'est à deux centimètres de rappel tu
vois ça tu te sens tu m'enlèves yeux
tourner un malade c'est un mature celle
qui en accouche audace à tulle a [ __ ]
nantes etc ou encore